at this point I think it's safe to say
that every Mortal Kombat has a big bad
villain an antagonist who drives the
main story forward the final boss of the
game with MK 11 we have the introduction
of Kronecker who is referred to as a
Titan a species that we've never seen
before that ranked even higher than the
Elder Gods in terms of power and status
there aren't many who were aware of the
Titans existence outside of Shao Kahn
and Raiden who up until they encountered
Kronecker believed them to be nothing
more than made-up stories a race of
beings who manipulate an influence time
unbeknownst to everyone else Kronecker
herself is referred to as the architect
of the destiny within the universe
meaning whatever happens and has
happened she already predetermined it's
difficult to describe her as purely evil
because what she desires is a balance
between good and evil within the
universe which does raise the question
why have we never seen her before the
explanation that were given relates to
her children shinnok and setri on
Sherlock being the god of death and
darkness and setri on the goddess of
life and light essentially makes them
each other's counterpart to the mother
these opposing ideas create an
equilibrium a perfect balance between
the two it is worth mentioning that she
doesn't really seem to care about her
children they just kind of exists to
help her create this truly balanced
universe however this balance is broken
when shinnok is beheaded and so
Kronecker decides that she must then
restart the entire timeline from the
beginning the power of altering time and
causing the past and present to collide
is just one of the many things that
Kronecker is capable of and Raiden does
mention that up until now she has
actually done this several times before
she is also capable of manipulating the
sands shooting beams of energy and
telekinesis
despite this her power isn't unlimited
and she can't just reset the timelines
whenever she wants to in order to use
her hourglass she must first draw power
from the earth roms life force and we do
also see her using Shang Tsung's Chronos
dolls to enhance her power further you
definitely can make the point that
Kronecker isn't your ordinary villain
because she has this higher calling that
isn't innately evil but she still is a
very unlikable character and not just
because she floats around wearing this
stupid piece of metal but because she's
completely obsessed of the idea of
balance anyone who disagrees with her
gets in the way of her perfect division
is essentially erased from history when
the timeline resets if we also consider
that everything happens because
Kronecker allows it to happen
then that does mean she's responsible
for everything good but that also means
that she has no problem watching and
recreating the same atrocities and acts
of evil
whenever the timeline is reset Kern
occurs most powerful ability is her
manipulation of time itself we see this
pretty early on when she brings
individuals from past timelines into the
present with the promise of a better
life if they assist her we then find out
that Raiden in his quest to defend Earth
room from evil has become cronikeys
biggest hurdle to achieve in this
perfect imbalance after Raiden behead
she knock an MK 10 that is essentially
the final straw Kronecker comes out of
hiding and decides to reset the timeline
once again Raiden is one of chronic ha's
biggest threats but alone he simply
cannot defeat her and this is where Liu
Kang comes into the story what she fears
the most is Liu Kang and Raiden working
together to stop her which is why in
every previous timeline there is a
conflict between the two which ends in
Liu Kang's death during this year story
Raiden begins to have flashbacks from
previous timelines and they are able to
prevent history from repeating itself
this year Raiden and Liu Kang then work
together do their weird little fusion
dance and become a fire Thunder demigod
and defeat Kronecker just as she once
feared with his new powers Liu Kang
becomes the new keeper of time and
discharged with rebuilding the timeline
from the very beginning there's no doubt
that this year story has divided opinion
and has some mixed reviews there are
some good ideas and then there are some
so good but I do like when it sets up
for the next game whether or not
kuroneko's going to stay dead do we
don't really know but with her
introduction into the story I think it's
fair to assume that there may be more
Titans than just Kronecker and maybe her
death will spark some kind of
retaliation from the rest of them if the
Titans are then going to be the main
villains of MK 12 it's reasonable to
believe that all of the current
characters would have to band together
and Liu Kang may have to bring back
previous characters from other timelines
could this mean MK 12 is going to bring
back characters from previous games if
not have an entire playable roster from
the entire franchise I don't know and if
I know NetherRealm neither do they but
let me know what your thoughts are